dropped out of school in lebanon's
economy collapsed more than four years
ago it was the only way for their
younger siblings to get a few years of
education but keeping them in school is
not easy
we couldn't keep the older children in
private schools and then we couldn't pay
for transportation and other fees for
all of them to go to public schools
everything is so expensive we need to
make difficult choices
it's a story heard time and again
especially in lebanon's northern region
where poverty levels are high
the UN agency providing Aid to Children
UNICEF is calling on the government to
allocate sufficient funds to ensure
Public Schools stay open and reform what
many have described as an oversized
system
there is about over 60 000 people
working in the overall Ministry of
Education for
primary secondary University and we see
that the ratio is one out of seven one
one teacher or for seven children and we
need to right size this would put an end
to A system that allows politicians to
use State institutions for their
personal interests at the expense of the
General Public
help from International donors has been
vital in keeping schools open last year
UNICEF says it spent more than 70
million dollars to support the education
sector and that included paying the
salaries of up to 12 500 teachers as
well as cash assistance to 70 000
children to keep them in school
teachers like hilal fatal have been
among the most affected by the economic
crisis and the extreme loss of the local
currency's value
we now rely on charity that's why I have
taken part in the ongoing strikes to try
to improve our situation but it's not
just a budget crisis there's so much
corruption and we have been paying the
price
the government says it's secure
secured of the 150 million dollars it
needs for the coming Academic Year while
lebanon's struggling population needs
help to keep their children in schools
an estimated 15 percent dropped out last
year alone
Tripoli Northern Lebanon
foreign